okay guys so let's meet alice alice uh
you contacted us about somebody you've
been dating since april can you explain
your story with
um by the way so this is
it's time date start stamp mark six days
ago so
april may june july august september
october november
it's a good length of time that these
two have been uh you know purportedly
dating but just listening it's rob
yeah hey
um guys doing great doing good
so
this guy that i've been really into
won't call me back we met on bumble back
in april
and i've just been so blessed to have
him in my life ever since
and as it stands now i haven't heard
from him in a week and i'm i'm pretty
shy about it
it's weird right yeah a week is a long
time
dating for what adam and i'm assuming
you've been messaging him and being like
hey how are you yeah hey boyfriend why
haven't i heard from you hello are you
okay yeah okay yeah
like i haven't heard anything you know
has there been anything that you you're
like
it could be this like you guys have an
argument just leaving a mouth guard in
that type of thing there's nothing wrong
with a mouth guard oh defensive are we
no no i mean nothing we've been great uh
lately you know we actually said i love
you for the first time
there's always her side of the story and
his side of the story and then what
really happened is oh we've been great i
don't understand why he's ghosting me
i'm such a victim listen just you know
pay attention here
oh it just it really hurts
i'm so hurt
you know like yeah it's just to just
mean nothing yeah okay you know what i
mean listen i think the only way to find
out is to find out so how about we give
him a shout
okay all right hang on
there we go just meeting alice uh the
story is this you've been dating this
guy since april alice and rob have been
together since april and in the last
week she has heard from him precisely
zero times and there wasn't like an
argument or anything that perpetuated
this so alice you're kind of confused
right
yeah guys
i mean let me just pause this for a sec
do you really think
she's confused
does she not have
any idea why this dude is not responding
to her
i'm gonna go with no
i'm gonna go with no on this but just
listen and we'll find out
i'm really i'm confused i'm hurt yeah
this is weird this is
too early in the morning let me try
again that was it's definitely hard
let's so alice here's the thing we're
gonna give rob a call with you listening
on the phone we're gonna get see if we
can extract an answer the problem
sometimes with this is that the answers
are extremely real and
can hurt the ego are you sure you want
to make this call
i mean i have to i need to know what's
going on that's fair yeah all right
let's give rob a call
yes let's give rob a call hello hi there
is this rob
uh this is him hi rob adam wild tj and
jax from 999 virgin radio good morning
hello
hey there the radio station that's us
very soon we are our show on the radio
station we're not the entire radio
station we have other teammates let's
talk about the relationship live on the
air didn't see how you're doing
alice in a week you know that sort of
thing
okay
what are they doing for throughout
that's why haven't you called alex
that's what really you notice right away
the chicks like why haven't you called
allison back it's like you know
the uber ally the sisterhood so it's
always there you know because she's
remember you know she's hurt she's
confused she's the victim here let's
find out what this guy's got to say why
we're calling yeah your girlfriend
uh
i mean honestly she's got the energy out
of me i mean i'm i'm just taking a break
from the apps for a while i just need
time to to just
i don't think i'll be dating for a while
um
i'm not sure i get what you're saying
can you extrapolate yeah what happened
i mean it's embarrassing uh but when you
fall in love i guess you could fall for
anything um
i thought that was it i i was i found
what i was looking for i was being
single for like three years i was
starting to doubt i was gonna find
anyone again
now let me just pause that for a sec the
dude just finished saying
he'd been single for three years
and he comple and was at the point where
you know he was doubting that he wasn't
gonna find anything this is usually when
guys make the most concessions
in their lives when it comes to women
this is where they'll start to ignore
red flags and
red flags let me just banner up for you
just so you get familiar if you're newer
to my channel
get on my email list and get the free
chapter from my book on the red flags i
just want you to pay attention here to
what this lady's going to go on about
because this is this is going to get
good in a second here just listen up and
then alice came along and she was
special like
she was special
[Laughter]
she was special she was she was the one
she was a unicorn
she was special he says she was special
mm-hmm
that's what happens when you know if
you're in the desert i can't remember
who made this joke it's a stand-up
obviously if you're in the desert and
you haven't eaten anything for a long
time and somebody gives you a salty and
cracker and you eat that salty and
cracker
that's gonna be the best damn thing you
ever put in your mouth
she was special because he had nothing
else going on for three i guarantee this
dude was not spinning plates or had any
other options going on but listen up
i thought that was it for me like we'd
go anywhere steakhouse ontario place
mcdonald's the whole world around
mcdonald's sounds like the world was
your oyster
it didn't matter where we were anywhere
we went it was it was special was this
yeah
and she made me feel full uh like
nuggets
then those times i just went here for
her for like like a couple days straight
there it is that worked i called
attached nothing
and she would hit me back with that
excuse every time and i i fell for it i
hooked a secret and i just i just
thought it becomes redundant honestly
so
okay i'm gonna break protocol here all
right we have alice on the line rob
alice can uh
can we discuss here because that's not
the story we got from you mm-hmm
oh my god i miss you so much i i gave
you the real reasons for why i wasn't
always
you know
available i mean
sometimes we need our space right
sometimes we need our space i gave you
the reasons rob why we're not always
well i'm not always available for you
sometimes we need our space
what do you think that space is fellas
just leave it in the comments right now
what do you think it looks like
right you know like you can't you can't
have me around all the time
and i just you know what can we just
forget it like i just need to see you
can can you come over tonight
i just need to see you can you come over
tonight my place
this is where the manipulation starts to
come around where they where they try to
suck you back in with what
the sexy time that's how they try to get
you back in now let's find out why she
needed her space pay attention
alice like just stop man just please
stop like we both know like what's going
on here you keep going back to your ex
like i saw and there it is
there it is there's the space
she keeps going back to her ex
oh his name pop up on your phone when
your phone was on the table
and like
i feel like when he's tired of you you
just come back to me like let's not do
this on the radio station no no
so
she's disagreeing obviously because why
would you want to acknowledge that
you've been behaving this way especially
on the radio
and he's saying well
i know why you needed your space now
he's calling her out on her and good for
him
good for him so you know solid move
solid move
he knew exactly what she was up to and
even
said to her
a few moments earlier
you only came to me
when you felt like it wasn't working out
with him
right the like women are professional
mate switchers i have a video somewhere
on my channel i have a study
um
on mate switching
and
where is it i printed out mommy's little
secret why women lose a dating game
where's my mate switching study
sexual economic sex as a female no i
must have filed it away i've got a video
on my channel somewhere look just just
search entrepreneurs and cars
and type in uh mate switching and i'm
sure it'll come up you can you can watch
it i did in the last year and a half or
so women are pros at moving from guy to
guy sometimes they go back and forth
like ping pong balls sometimes they'll
just move from one dude to the other
there's really no single women out there
you know a lot of guys would be like oh
well she's single or think or ask women
well are you single well there's don't
even bother asking because
all women have options i mean if they're
reasonably attractive they always have
options right
so don't think of respect that she's
single
this one here when he met her on a
dating app was still dealing with her ex
and flip-flopping back and forth from
her from him to the other dude and back
and forth and now
for whatever reason it didn't work out
between her and this other dude so she
decides to call him up on the air to try
to reconcile because he's ghosted her
and it's all backfiring on her because
he's calling her because he's actually
calling her out on it which is good
let's see where it goes
oh craig and i are through like for good
this time this time came over to my
place and i wouldn't even let him in
liar you have to buzz them in though
so like so why wasn't i able to hear
from you for like days like did that
make sense
i needed space like
i needed space he says so why didn't i
hear from you for days
i needed space
let me show you what the space looks
like do i have my space
oh hang on a sec let me let me show you
what the space looks like
share screen i got this cued up i'm the
meme lord today guys i am your meme lord
there's your space
i just needed some space
there it is right there
let's uh let's continue on with this uh
oh man i need my faith
come on stream here i'd work with me
sorry i'm gonna have to cue this back up
uh
stop screen share
share screen
and boom there we go
okay you guys should be able to hear
this
and continue
like i keep telling you we need space
sometimes alice you got to communicate
that though like you can't just go m.i.a
i know i thought i thought i had i just
okay
can we just stop like that is all all of
that is in the past now i just want i
want you i only want you okay
let me um let me explain something to
you about past and future okay when it
comes to the
dynamics between attraction with men and
women
a guy is more interested in a woman's
past
a woman is more interested in a guy's
financial future and when i say past him
i'm more specifically talking about her
sexual past right that's what he's
interested in and
she
has been running around like the village
bicycle
in town and all of a sudden she's
realized that this guy is the best that
she can do so she's pleading to have him
back
and
let's hear what he does
tonight
i'm over tonight she says
so wait so you'll you're never going to
talk to craig again oh no dude never
baby i love you and oh i love you he's
falling for it you know i miss you and i
know you miss me
i miss you so much
so where does this leave us this
did she love him and miss him so much
when she ghosted his ass for days on end
when she was hanging out with the other
dude what was his name greg craig or
something like that i didn't catch the
name okay no it's just
um rob how do you feel yeah rob
i think we should i think we should talk
about this privately honestly
how do you feel being second backs
around
uh so let me ask you okay um uh uh alex
and rob are you getting together later
tonight
yes
right we are right we're gonna talk
about this
we'll see each other later are we sure
we want to do that
yes she does obviously yes
are you sure rob yeah rob i'll be there
we'll we'll do that
we'll meet up that sounds like a
confidence
okay all right well listen this this
worked out great we'll send you guys uh
the the a delivery gift card and yeah
we'll your your date's on us good luck
okay there we go that brings me back to
the point of genuine burning desire the
third chapter in my book if you guys
haven't read the unplugged alpha get it
it's on amazon print and kindle the
audible version is narrated by yours
truly
you